now stay Diane this is another 70s
classic and it deserves a serious
comeback right sounds a little bit weird
but we're gonna season the board
okey-dokey there we are don't worry I'm
not gonna make you eat the board now
from there
steaks on top of the board okay lay them
out so there's a bit of a chef's thing
this thing you know that's so again it
with season on top salt pepper and now
Steak Diane classically is done with the
minutes takes I'm gonna roll a nice and
thinly I can't show have a little roll
Kirsty yeah over now as you roll the
steaks out I usually come nice too thin
and be gonna come really nice and
seasoned inside all that salt in that
pepper goes in look at that beautiful
nice excellent yes as we're looking over
there now pan yes yeah it's on hands on
yeah nice how are we supposed to get
more into the pan yeah I'll show you now
now have you ever used an open ring or
are you so used to you so now you so you
see your arghya cuz you're not okay yeah
no I always do about that kind of round
yes my Agha right this is the British
therapist aristocracy no no not really
no okay so we almost can also yes
first time on a gas ring yeah it's true
you're going red right stakes into the
pan
lay them away from me my darling okay
okay like that yes like that
trust me yeah there we go specials
overhaul yeah okay a nice thing about
these throughout this season you got the
salt and pepper inside now is this not
the good they obviously shrink okay a
tablespoon of olive oil back is a fine
plan okay okay yes I think such a
warning though and now we're going to
start the Saudi potato okay steaks a
color in nicely potatoes have drained
beautifully yeah okay
well done right ready okay potatoes in
nice okay good now that's on get a
little bit of rosemary and stick down
with your potatoes okay
nice fresh fragrant rose me right now
where did your obsession with property
come from its genetic all my family are
obsessed with rock so does that mean you
grow you grew up in the palace
no it means like
oh don't worry don't worry
okay there we go okay now don't worry
got no batteries is a pepper grinder
thank you guys
now seriously okay there's a slight
confidence crisis out there there is a
crisis out of a job now oh no Phil and I
keep it going this it's actually giving
people advice and hard times is what
really matters right so any advice out
there ah keep your head and don't panic
yeah there you go